>>Female Presenter: OK. Good afternoon. Welcome.
My name is Alana Weiss from the Google EDU
team and today, it is my pleasure to welcome
Stan Slap to the Leading@Google series. For
Stan Slap, emotional commitment for managers
is the Holy Grail for explosive results.
Today, he'll speak to his first book titled
"Bury My Heart at Conference Room B: The Unbeatable
Impact of Truly Committed Managers," which
was on the top five on the bestseller lists
of the New York Times, USA Today, and the
Wall Street Journal. It was also named one
of the best books of year by Inc Magazine
and Fast Company.
Stan Slap is the president of the international
consulting company called, by a remarkable
coincidence, Slap. And following a history
of accomplishments as a CEO and advisor, Stan
is now focused on influencing managers at
today's fastest growing companies through
his work as a corporate strategist and trainer.
Stan Slap is intent on making a profound difference
in the world before he is forcibly removed
from it and because that is the mission that
Googlers can definitely identify with, please
join me in welcoming Stan Slap.
[applause]
>>Stan Slap: All right. How are you doing?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: Good.
[audience murmurs in response]
>>Stan Slap: Good, good. All right. Listen.
Before we even get started here, I know that
you're here for any number of reasons, but
one of the reasons must be to learn. And there
are two ways to learn anything. I mean this,
though. There's data and there's experience.
And there's two types of experience. There's
good experience. There's bad experience. And
even though we all like to claim we're nibbling
from the higher branches by this point in
our evolution, let's face it. It's most often
the bad experience that finally claims our
attention, which is why, before we even get
started today, I would like to dedicate our
time together to the one company which in
recent memory has committed the most boneheaded
act.
An act that is not just so anti-business sense,
it's so anti-common sense that it can only
be interpreted as a noble act, as a selfless
gesture so the rest of us may learn what not
to do and so, grow and prosper in our own
organizations. Now, competition for the dedication-spot
in this talk has been predictably fierce,
but my company does business in over 70 countries,
so I thought I'd look globally for the dedication
spot.
And I think I've found the company that is
worthy of that honor. So, I would like to
dedicate our time together today to Aeroflot,
the Russian airline. [audience chuckles] Has
anybody here ever flown Aeroflot? Great. Has
anybody here ever flown United? Yeah, you've
flown Aeroflot. Pretty much the same thing.
[laughter]
And by the way, everything I tell you here
today is true. Aeroflot management, in a desperate
bid to cure sagging revenue, has leaped upon
a new consumer campaign which they announced
recently in the business press in Eastern
Europe. And according to Aeroflot, in this
article where they announced it, this campaign
is their first ever, what they call "Smile
Day."
And according to Aeroflot management, on Smile
Day every employee at the airline will be
under orders to quote, "smile unceasingly
at customers for the entire day." It's like.
[laughter]
And they were asked in this same article,
"Well, what if Smile Day is a success?" And
their official corporate spokesperson responded,
"If Smile Day is a success, we will consider
implementing it on an annual basis." All right.
[chuckles]
[laughter]
And I thought, "You know, it is exactly this
treatment of effect over cause, of symptom
over sickness that's responsible for the chronic
ills that business faces today." It's not
just Google.
The problems that continue to baffle and bedevil
managers in every company and every industry
in every line of business on every team in
every country are not really new problems.
The biggest problem is that the solutions
are not really new solutions. Now, nowhere
is that more the case then when it comes to
a subject like leadership, which is what I'm
gonna talk to you about today.
Now, leadership, [chuckles] that's a big subject.
We could spend a lifetime talking about leadership.
I don't have a lifetime to spend talking to
you about leadership. I have about 40 minutes.
So, I figured I had a choice. [sniffs] I could
make the 40 minutes seem like a lifetime to
you.
[laughter]
Or I could focus on what's most important.
Today, I am gonna focus on what's most important.
I guess good news and bad news about this.
The good news is I happen to know a lot about
leadership. My company's leadership solution,
which is called "Bury My Heart at Conference
Room B" is the highest rated management development
process in many of the world's highest rated
companies.
That took about ten years to build and we
beta tested for another ten years amongst
tens of thousands of managers around the world.
The book version, this thing. This took a
while to write, too. And I wrote it backed
by a 23-person research team, including Pulitzer-winning
investigative journalists and specialists
in psycho-neurobiology.
So, bottom line is I happen to know a lot
about this particular subject. I can actually
show you exactly how to be a leader. The bad
news is I've got like 40 minutes to do that.
This is like a 40-minute workshop on the principles
of neurosurgery. So, grab those knives and
good luck.
I can't possibly explain to you exactly how
to become a leader in 40 minutes. But here's
what I can do. There is more mythology, misdirection,
superstition, and generalized academic babble
about leadership than almost any business
subject. I can bust the most dangerous myths
once and for all for you.
Right here. Right now. I can give you a little
taste of what leadership would look like in
your own organization if you applied it. I
can tell you once and for all the difference
between management and leadership, if you
ever really wondered about that. And if I
can't show you exactly how to become a leader,
I could do the one thing far more important
than that.
I can show you exactly why you should become
a leader, because that is one of the biggest
myths of leadership is that it's a practice.
Leadership is not a practice, not something
else you have to do as a manager. Leadership
is a purpose. It's a motivation.
There is no leadership school in history that
can claim history's greatest leaders as alumni.
They all just started somewhere, figured it
out. I can show you what has caused every
iconic leader in history to pull that trigger
on the ignition switch that kick started their
leadership.
And I can make it immaculately relevant for
you at Google. And I'm talking to you as managers.
So, let me just real quick find out. How many
of you in this room are actually managers
with headcount? Raise your delicate, well-manicured
fingers please. [audience chuckles] OK. And
then, how many of you would classify yourself
more as the managed?
Raise your tough, calloused, working-class
hands please.
[laughter]
Yeah, OK. So, if you're the managed, I'm gonna
show you the greatest secret of managing successfully
as well, which is found in this whole thing.
And this is certainly relevant for the people
who've chosen to be managers. Don't you start
getting all snarly and cocky in here, going
"heh heh heh."
Your career could take a sudden wrong turn.
You could become a manager and you're gonna
wish you'd listened to this information. [laughter]
In the meantime, you're still managing something
at Google. You're managing conceptually yourself.
You're managing part of Google's business.
You're managing others. You're managing your
life. So, I think this will still be relevant
to you. Now, let's get to the big myths of
leadership. And the way I'm gonna do that
is I'm gonna ask and answer some questions
for you. And we'll bust these myths. I'd be
happy to take questions at the end, but let
me get through some of the big ones now for
you.
The first, probably the biggest is, "Is leadership
important?" Well, let me answer this for you
conclusively. No. We can just stop here, right?
Thank you.
[laughter]
See how much you learn at these things? No.
Leadership is not important. Leadership is
absolutely meaningless. Now, what leadership
provides, that's very important. You know,
you can go on Amazon.com as an example. You
can type in "books leadership."
How many titles do you think are available
right now under the subject heading of leadership?
And I actually did this when I wrote "Bury
My Heart at Conference Room B" and they breed
like rabbits. So, I don't know how many are
there now, but I have an actual number for
you.
How many titles do you think are available?
Thousands. Fifty thousand. Keep going.
[laughter]
You know what? I'm gonna skip the suspense
'cause I know Googlers are trying to crack
this code for the next hour. Three hundred
and eighty thousand, five hundred and sixty
seven titles. Eighty-four percent of those
books, written in the last fifteen years.
Ninety-one percent about something called
"business leadership."
You ever wonder where all this incessant babble
in the enterprise about leadership comes from?
It comes from the one thing that any company
wants most from it's managers: emotional commitment.
A manager's emotional commitment is the ultimate
trigger for their discretionary effort.
It's worth more than your financial, intellectual,
and physical commitment combined. A manager's
emotional commitment, that's the stuff that
solves problems that are unsolvable. It creates
energy when all the energy has been expended.
And it ignites emotional commitment in others,
like employees and teams and customers.
Any legendary sustained organizational success
is at the root, the result of a bunch of emotionally
committed managers. And leaders are those
rare human beings in history who have emotional
commitment to a cause and who can inspire
it at-will in other people.
Now, any manager in this room joining, any
manager watching this on YouTube, joining
any manager in the world can appear fully
productive and enthusiastic simply because
you are intellectually, financially, and physically
committed.
But if you've ever witnessed a human being
emotionally committed to a cause, working
like they're being paid a million and they're
not being paid a dime, you know there's a
difference. You know it's big. It's that difference
a company wants from its managers.
Just because it's big doesn't mean it's easy.
The key neurobiological source of emotional
commitment in any human being--this is not
me telling you this--this is your brain telling
you this. [audience laughs lightly] The key
neurobiological source of emotional commitment
is your ability to live your own deepest personal
values in whatever relationship or environment
that you're involved in.
Or if you're a manager, that means your relationship
with Google, your environment at work. Now,
manager may be a great job to have. If you're
a manager, you may be having a great time
doing that job. But embedded in any manager's
job description is the requirement to continually
subordinate or even compromise personal values
in favor of company priorities.
Now I'm not saying you're out there committing
heinous acts as part of some Faustian bargain.
Although, even if you are, listen up. What
I am saying is what the company wants done
and how it wants it done must regularly take
precedence over your own deep priorities.
That's what it means to be a manager. You
serve your company first. Well, if you put
a person in a position like that, they detach
to protect themselves. Now, in a bad company.
Have any of you ever worked in a nasty, toxic,
belly of the beast company? Yeah? OK.
In those kinds of companies, managers make
the conscious choice to detach. Managers in
those nasty companies, they say to themselves,
"I'm gonna suit up every day for the detachment
factory and leave the best of who I am at
home and hope that it's basically still there
when I get home to reclaim it."
But in a good company like this company that
tries to do the right thing for its managers,
the detachment is even more dangerous because
it can't be easily seen. Because intellectual
and financial and physical commitment combined
to masquerade as the missing type.
But emotional commitment is different. It's
deeper. It comes from a deeper, different
place. And if this isn't understood and the
ability for managers to sustain this on their
own, isn't really embedded into the organization,
then any hope of emotional commitment is lost.
And lost with it is any hope of real leadership.
So let's talk about real leadership again
for a minute. If you go back to those 380,567
books on leadership, take a look at them.
They all pretty much tell you the same thing.
They will tell you that the purpose of leadership
is to increase shareholder value and team
productivity.
That is not actually the purpose of leadership.
That has never been the purpose of leadership.
That will never be the purpose of leadership.
The irreducible essence of leadership is that
leaders are human beings who live their own
deepest values without compromise.
And they use those values to make life better
for other people. Now, that's why people become
leaders and that's why people follow leaders.
So the question is, can the people in this
room, whether you're a manager or not, become
a real leader? Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, leadership is not some rare genetic
imperative. It's innate in every human being
and it's damn well innate in you. You just
have to know where to get started. If you
study the chronology of every iconic leader
in history, their leadership all starts in
pretty much the same place: with their personal
values being put under tremendous pressure.
You wanna know if something's important to
you? Meet somebody trying to take it away.
Well, that same pressure is on your values
if you're a manager. It's just harder to realize.
Because the pressure on a manager's personal
values arrives gift wrapped. It arrives with
financial reinforcement.
It arrives with this sense of self to be gained
by affiliating with the might and magnificence
of the company. Besides, there isn't any company
that actually wants its managers to be leaders.
Really. Study leadership throughout human
history. Leaders are people who use their
own values and vision to overthrow the established
order and set everybody free.
What are you? Nuts? This is the last thing
any company wants its managers to be particularly
interested in, or capable of. The company
just wants managers to do the things that
leaders do, like model selfless acts of devotion.
And inspire a sullen group of individuals
to make a bloody charge up Competitor's Hill
to capture the fourth quarter flag.
And what the company really wants from its
managers is emotional commitment. And there's
nothing wrong with that. But listen up. That's
not why you should be a leader. As a manager,
your most important responsibility is to Google.
As a leader, your most important responsibility
is to yourself.
You must fulfill your personal responsibility
first. It's far from being a subversive act.
This is actually the single most supportive
corporate action you could ever take. The
bottom line about leadership is that you will
never really work for your company until you
company really works for you.
And if you think that this is a problem that
somehow has escaped Google, just because Google
is a great company, which it unquestionably
is, let me give you a little stat. The first
time we put ten thousand managers through
the "Bury My Heart at Conference Room B" process,
the full process, we went back and looked
at some data that came out of those sessions.
And these are ten thousand managers from over
70 countries from many of the world's most
admired companies from executive to entry
level. And we asked those managers, "Well,
if the source of emotional commitment is living
your deepest personal values, what are your
deepest personal values? What do you care
most about as people?"
And that's not a test. There's no right or
wrong answers to that question. But there
were certainly some choices made more often
than others. The number one and two values
most often chosen by managers--and we do this
every time we hit another ten thousand--and
it's always the same.
Here's the first ten thousand. Ten thousand
managers. The number one and two values chosen
by those managers as most important. Number
one was family. Number two was integrity.
And we asked those same ten thousand managers
across seventy countries from executive to
entry level, and from many of the world's
most admired organizations, "So, what are
the personal values you're most under pressure
to compromise on a regular basis to do your
job successfully?" Watch me now. This goes
very quickly.
[whistles]
[laughter]
You better file that under big trouble. You
are looking at the equation for emotional
detachment. And since leadership is the organizing
framework for an emotional commitment, that's
why we're talking about leadership. And that
brings us to the next question. "Do you have
to be born a leader?" No.
Nobody is born a leader. You just have to
do the things that leaders do for the reasons
that leaders really do them. Now, the number
one thing that separates a leader from a normal
human being is that a leader really knows
who they are as a human being. I mean, they
really know who they are.
A leader knows themselves so well, they could
put a name on their core values. And most
of us don't really know ourselves that well.
We may be driven by our core values. We may
be driven crazy by not meeting our core values.
It doesn't mean we really know what those
values are.
It doesn't mean that we are making daily decisions
to protect and to promote what's truly most
important to us. Leaders are different. They
know this about themselves. And because a
leader knows exactly who they are, they know
exactly where they wanna go in the world.
They wanna go to a place where their values
are fully realized. Martin Luther King, Jr.
as a young man discovers pretty early on he's
got core values of what, freedom, spirituality,
equality. So, he knows where he wants to go.
He wants to go to a place where those values
are fully in play.
He calls it, "I Have a Dream." The only problem
is he can't make that dream happen all by
himself. It's too big. He's gotta turn his
values into a compelling cause for other people.
I can tell you, that's where and why leadership
starts. It's right there. Leaders do apparently
selfless things for the world, but at heart,
they're very self-centered people.
They're gonna do it for you because they desperately
need you to do something for them. I mean,
if a leader knew who they were and so they
knew where they wanted to go, and they knew
how to get there, they'd just go. They'd send
you a postcard from the Promised Land. "I
have a dream. You're not in it."
[laughter]
But they need you. And so, if you were a world
leader, your leadership will be taking place
on the world stage. You are a Google manager,
then your leadership takes place in your organization.
That's where the pool of your potential followers,
the people that are gonna make your values
happen, are gonna come from.
And so, what would it sound like to translate
that concept? Well, I'll give you a little
taste. This isn't the entire equation. Otherwise,
it would've been a pamphlet instead of a book.
But I'll give you a little taste of what it
would sound like. Let's say, like many managers
do, you have family as one of your deepest
personal values.
Now, if you were a leader, you'd have the
kind of self-awareness to understand why.
Why, out of a world of possibilities, you
pick family as one of your core values. So,
you would actually know beyond the literal
definition of family what family gives you
as a concept that makes it so important to
you.
So, let's say you thought about it and said,
"What do I get from my family? I get open,
honest communication. I get unconditional
support. When I need it, I get tough love.
But if I stumble and fall, in my family, they'll
be there to scoop me up and put me back on
my hind legs.
And in my family, I am surrounded by people
who put my welfare ahead of their own. And
they inspire me to do the same for them."
There isn't a righteous feeling in the world
that can touch that. And that's why family
is so important to me. And I'm not gonna do
without that over half waking hours at work.
Well, you'd have to make that very important
to your people. So, you'd have to use that
value to promise them better working conditions.
You'd have to say something like this to your
people. Of course, you'd also have to prove
it, but you'd have to say something like this
as a first announcement, "Let me tell you
what life is gonna start looking like on this
team.
Number one, you will never again put your
job and your family into conflict without
giving me the chance to do something about
it. Your job and your family will be strangers
no more. You're doing good, important work
here. As we celebrate that for you, we're
roll that celebration right out to your family,
that people that make it possible for you
to get in here every day and do that good
work.
And when something great is going on for you
at home, don't you dare think you have to
leave it locked up at home. You roll it in
here. We'll cheer you on. But, God forbid,
something serious ever goes wrong for you
at home. I want you to know you'll have the
strength and support of this family.
Because we're like family here, too. We're
here together all the time. It's time we started
acting like a family. And I mean the very
best families. This team will have open, honest
communication. This team will have unconditional
support. When we need it, this team will have
tough love.
But under pressure, this team will never turn
on this team. Now, this team will come together
to protect this team. Because that's what
families do. And family is very important
to me." Now, do you think your people are
gonna reject a message like this from you?
Oh, my God.
Your people are dying for a message like this
from you. They're dying for what leadership
really represents, which is righteous cause
and trust at the highest levels. And all that
Maslow stuff that you probably dozed off about
during management school--significance, belonging,
self-worth, core emotional fulfillment.
If your people had not bought something like
this from you, that just means you're not
selling it. They're dying, dying for this
from you. And leadership is very hard to find
in the world today. If they can touch at any
place, particularly at a place that they live
in half their waking hours, they're going
to respond to it.
And this brings up the difference between
management and leadership that I promised
you. Here is the basic, short-form difference
between management and leadership. Any management
message that you ever hear, no matter how
expensively and eloquently delivered to you
it is, whether it comes to you on a small
screen in your hand, whether it comes to you
in the big screen at a Google off-site, whether
there's free clothing involved, whether Google
got the Village People to play together again.
I thought all those guys were dead. Whatever
it is, any management message that you ever
hear is simply an equation that ends only
one way. Equals work harder. That's a management
message. But any leadership message that you
ever hear, any real, authentic leadership
message is also an equation that ends only
way.
Equals live better. Now, I can tell you what.
If you're a manager, your people are not gonna
work harder unless they are convinced it is
going to allow them to live better. Of course,
the same goes for you. That's what we're talking
about here. So, will Google reject this?
Well, Google is--. We've put "Bury My Heart
at Conference Room B" into some of the organizations
at Google and it got rave reviews. They didn't
reject it at all. Struggled with it a bit.
But didn't reject it. Will Google, the company,
reject this? No.
Here's, from a company perspective, I can
tell you as an ex-CEO, I didn't realize this
at the time, but from a company perspective
when you're looking at a manager culture,
the biggest issue for a company when it comes
to its managers is protecting against the
constant dilution of energy from its managers.
'Cause if you're a manager, you only have
so much energy.
And most of that energy is already tapped.
So first of all, just doing the job. That
dial is cranked to ten all the time. Or we
say, "The managers eat from a magic plate.
It doesn't matter how much you swallow, nothing
ever seems to disappear." And so that dial
is--.
All your energy is being used just to do the
job. But doing the job is not the entire job
for a manager. You also have to constantly
incorporate the new and the more in that job.
And the first dial is not gonna turn down
for the second dial. If you have any shreds
of energy left, you're gonna spend it staying
sane on the job while you're trying to do
the first two things.
And so, managers are just tapped out. And
yet, the company still wants you to do more
and more and bigger and bigger and harder
and harder stuff. Where is that energy gonna
come from if those dials never turn down?
Managers are gonna go to fumes.
That's all they got left. And if a manager
goes to fumes, that kind of energy, you may
seem like a manic, multitasking PDA checking
change agent. But that energy? That's nasty
energy. That energy is killing you at the
same time it's juicing you. It's not the kind
of energy that is the same as sustained emotional
commitment.
That energy is toxic energy. It's neurobiologically
toxic energy and ultimately becomes cynical
energy. Exhausted energy. There isn't a strategy
or goal that Google can conceive and drop
onto a platform of that kind of manager energy
that will ever be dependably weight bearing.
So, the question is, is how do you give managers
more energy and take the weight off the enterprise
while you're doing it? Because nobody's got
any more time to figure this out. You have
to shift the energy source to an individual
energy source. A self-sustaining, self-reinforcing
energy source.
That's what "Bury My Heart at Conference Room
B" is all about, by the way. If you could
turn your job into a mechanism for fulfilling
your deepest personal values, you will protect
that mechanism by making the company even
more successful than it is right now.
'Cause now, in addition to everything else
Google does for you, it's doing something
even more important. Whether it realizes it
or not, it would be giving you the opportunity
to understand how to do this. You cannot live
your values without the support of your people.
If your people don't know what those values
are and don't care, you don't have a shot
at this. So, if you turn your values into
better working conditions for your people,
you're people are gonna protect you. Now,
as a manager, you stop being a replaceable
commodity.
They don't want anything to happen to you
now. So, how are they gonna keep you safe?
Give us the performance objectives. We've
got that. You stay right where you are. That's
why companies who don't have patience as a
corporate value love "Bury My Heart at Conference
Room B."
And it's this energy that is the biggest issue
for managers. So, let me wrap up this brief
overview. Is that redundant? Brief overview?
Let me wrap up this overview by reframing
this first question. And I already asked this
question on your behalf. Is leadership important?
And I answered it for you based on twenty
plus years of in-depth work on this subject.
No, it is not important. That's not exactly
the right answer. The right answer is yes,
it is important. It is very important. Why
is leadership important? Because leadership
is the organizing framework for emotional
commitment. And that's critical.
Emotional commitment will do a lot of things
for you if you have to manage people. If you
have to get results through other people,
this is the best way to do it. People will
follow you as a leader. They will not follow
you as a manager. Nobody is gonna line up
behind you as a manager except maybe to push
you down the stairs.
But as a leader, they are going to follow
you and they're gonna listen to you and they're
gonna have faith in you and they're gonna
grow with you. Those are leadership things.
But there is one other benefit to doing this
that trumps all those things. So, I have a
brief interactive portion here for you.
I'll ask it of all of you, managers can certainly
answer. I don't know where to start the voting,
so I'm gonna just start it very low. I don't
mean to be patronizing to you when I ask you
this question. Somebody pulled that on me
last week. He said, "I don't mean to be patronizing
to you.
That means when I'm talking down to you."
I said, "I know what patronizing means." So,
I don't mean to be patronizing to you, which
means when I'm talking down to you. OK? But
we gotta start the voting somewhere. So, let
me just ask, how many of you in this room
work 40 or more hours a week?
Raise your hands. OK. I ask this question
because I put this argument that I just put
in front of you, in front of managers all
over the world all the time. And I've had
managers all the time say to me, "You're talking
about my personal values? Of course I live
my personal values.
In my personal life. I protect and promote
my personal values, but I'm also a manager.
So, yes. In my personal life, I protect and
promote my personal values. And then every
morning when they clamp the helmet down on
that Hazmat suit that says "Manager" across
the back and I go into the office, I'm all
over the company values."
That's beautiful. That is very inspiring,
but there is one dangerous flaw in this common
management logic. So, most of you work 40
or more hours a week here. How about, anybody
here working 45 or more hours a week? Raise
your hands. I'm not gonna bite you. [audience
murmurs]
That should go likewise. I don't wanna be
bitten for this, all right? This is just the
way it is. All right. How many of you work
50 hours a week or more, if you netted it
out, week in, week out? Raise your hands.
OK. Anybody pulling 55 hours a week or more?
OK. [chuckles] Anybody doing 60 hours a week
or more?
OK. So, what. Can we say on average it's 50
hours a week, week in, week out? Or is it
less? Tell me. Let me explain what I mean
by interactive, OK? [chuckles]
[laughter]
Listen, I'm not gonna hurt you 'cause you're
already hurting yourself. That would be kind
of the point. So, 50 hours a week? [audience
answers] It's like special home room here.
OK, good. So, 50 hours a week or more. How
about travel time? The time you spend getting
back and forth to work or traveling for work.
I assume you're not all dazed, feral road
warriors. Is that at least another ten hours
a week that you spend traveling? OK. Now,
thank you. Now, we are at 50 hours a week--uhh,
60 hours a week. You're working 50. You're
traveling ten. How about think time?
The time you're not actually on the job, but
you're thinking about the job? How many hours
a week is that? That's just the rest of the
time, right? Think about this. How many hours
a week do you think you spend not actually
engaged in doing the job, but thinking about
the job, worrying about the job, obsessing
about the job, talking to somebody outside
the job about the job, waking up screaming
about the job?
[laughter]
Could that be in a seven-day span? Another
15 hours a week? Easy, right? Now we're at
75 hours a week. You're working 50. You're
traveling ten. You're thinking about work
15. Well, I'm gonna skip the entire mathematical
formula for you. I'm just gonna give you the
bottom line.
At a combined 75 hours a week, between work
time, travel time, and think time, each and
every manager in this room and anybody else
who answered that way is spending on average
more than double your waking hours working
than not working. Welcome to your personal
life. [audience chuckles]
You think you get these hours back? Death
sends you an email. I know you're Google managers.
You think, "I would just delete that email
from Death without reading it and I will live
forever." It does not work that way. This
is it. This is it. These are the irretrievable
hours of your personal life.
And no matter how fulfilling and rewarding
financially, intellectually, this job may
be, to not live your deepest personal values
over half your waking hours is a crime. What's
worse, it's an unnecessary crime. Google is
not deliberately saying to you, "Do not meet
your personal values at work."
I mean, unless one of your personal values
is like, corporate embezzlement or something.
There's plenty of room for both. Yes, you
have a job and a responsibility as a manager.
And that is to protect and promote Google's
values and Google's vision for the world.
Side by side with that responsibility, you
have an opportunity, which is to protect and
promote your own values and your own vision.
And if you do that right, jumping on that
opportunity will never hurt your responsibility.
In fact, it will make most of your responsibility
happen for you.
So, why should you become a leader? Because
leadership, if you deconstruct leadership,
it's all about emotional commitment. If you
deconstruct emotional commitment, it's all
about living your deepest personal values.
Why should you live your deepest personal
values?
Well, your deepest personal values are your
very own definition of what life looks like
when you live it exactly the way you want
to. Your values are your very own source of
safety, of hope, of renewal. Well, why should
you live your deepest personal values at work?
This is an excellent question to ask. If your
attorneys are planning an insanity defense
because you're spending over half your waking
hours here. Because you don't get this time
back. Because this is a corporate organism
you're working in. It's got its own life force
and its own priorities.
To live it, to make living your deepest personal
values a passive process in an environment
that's not a benign environment is a very
dangerous thing to do. Because your values
will ultimately result in your leadership.
And your humanity cannot be self-proclaimed.
It is only activated when you offer it to
others. Because if you don't know what's true
for you, everyone else has unusual influence.
If you're not on your own agenda, you're prey
to everybody else's. Because those ten thousand
managers who said, "Family and integrity are
very important to me.
Family and integrity are the things that I
compromise to be successful." They weren't
saying "family is being compromised because
I don't have work/life balance." They were
saying family is being compromised because
the dependable support and affection and community
I get from my family, I'm not getting in a
place I spend half my waking hours.
They didn't say integrity is being compromised
because I'm being forced to lie, cheat, and
steal to make my numbers. They said my integrity
is being compromised because there is a disturbingly
low amount of integrity between who I really
am and who I am at work.
Now, I don't wanna stand up here acting all
emotionally evolved in front of you. That's
actually a violation of my parole. The whole
thing was taken completely out of context.
But I can tell you this. I will tell you this.
This is your one and only precious life. Now,
somebody is gonna decide how it's gonna be
lived.
And that person had better be you. So, is
leadership important? Yes. Leadership is actually
the most important thing you will ever do.
And let me just wrap this up and then I'm
happy to take any questions from you. I wanna
wrap this up. I was wondering how I should
end this.
And I'm gonna end it by answering a question
I'm asked all the time. I am regularly asked
this question from the C-suite, or from individual
managers, or employees, but mostly from managers.
The question is, if you had just one recommendation
you could give to any manager in any company
in any position anywhere in the world, you
could only tell them one thing.
What is the one most urgent recommendation
you would give to any manager? And I love
it when people turn my life's work into a
game show question, but I've had a chance
to think about it. I'm gonna leave you with
this today. For yourself, because it's your
life that's at stake here.
This time, the time you're spending on the
job, you don't get this time back. Your life
is happening to you right now. For your family,
because the health your family outside the
job, depends in large part on the health of
your family inside the job. If you're a manager
for your people, because it's not easy working
in environments with constant uncertainty
and pressure.
With regular reminder of how little control
you have over your work life, for someone
who you only know as "my manager." For your
customers, because people don't trust companies.
They trust people. For the company itself,
because Google is not a technology company.
Don't ever make that mistake. Google is a
human company selling technology to other
humans. And the pivot point upon which any
strategic success rests is a discretionary
effort of its human organization. And you
can't sell it outside if you can't sell it
inside.
And finally, for the world, because let's
face it. Things are very weird out there right
now. I'm not just talking economically. The
world is a scary, uncertain, shaken place.
And we actually have every indication that
things are gonna get a whole lot weirder before
they get any better.
Now what is it that any of the good people
gathered here together today in this room
can possibly do about the conditions that
affect the world at large? [laughs briefly]
Not much. Except to extend our own humanity
to the people that we are closest to, including
the people that we see every day, including
our employees and our customers.
And so for all of those reasons, I urge you,
to be human first and a manager second. OK.
Thank you.
[applause]
Yes.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: I have a question.
So, if you talk all like your manager and
leaders. The question is that if your manager
is not a leader, should I look for a leader
or preferably another manager?
>>Stan Slap: So if your manager is not, is
very clearly not a leader. Do you wanna get
up here on film with me? So, an anonymous
question from, it could be anybody in this
whole section, saying, "My manager is not
a leader. What do I do? Do I go looking for
a leader, or do I stay and take my stand right
here?"
I would say it's a version of the same question
that managers ask about if I can't live with
my values here, do I leave? I would give you
the same advice. I wouldn't leave for a couple
reasons. First of all, no manager may be any
different for you and this may ultimately
be the best manager you've ever worked with.
The bigger issue and the bigger solution is
to help your manager learn how to be a leader.
And I gotta tell you, it's just not something
that you really learn being a manager. The
biggest challenge, if you're a manager, is
to unlearn the job of being a manager 'cause
there's so much stupidity in there.
One of the things that managers learn very
early on--not working at Google necessarily--but
if they've ever managed anywhere, you learn
as a manager either directly from somebody
else or it just seeps into your DNA. You learn
that you need to manage.
The reason that your job exists and the reason
you need to control and watch people is that
you fundamentally cannot trust the employee
culture to protect the company with its own
good judgment. So, you have to manage them.
And that's just ridiculous. But you learn
that sort of thing.
And I will tell you as well that from your
position, you think about clawing your way
to the top at Google, you can cling to the
illusion that everything will be figured out
and fulfilling when you get there. I gotta
tell you, I know a lot of those people from
a lot of companies.
When you get there and find that things still
don't make sense, and now you're maybe a culture
of one and you can't admit what doesn't feel
good 'cause you got all the apparent rewards
of the job. And there's no place else to go.
People jump from the top floors in buildings,
not the bottom. Have you noticed that?
[laughter]
So, I would say it would be a kindness for
you to tell your manager, "Listen. I'm gonna
make a deal with you on the business. You
wanna get the best out of me? I'm willing
to give it to you. Here's the way to do it.
If for no other reason, if not just for understanding
what this team is truly capable of in terms
of commitment and loyalty, 'cause you may
have the wrong idea about that. I can tell
you how to get the best out of me."
But also, I would make it a values conversation.
This is not soft stuff. This is the stuff
of hardcore results. Your manager's got values,
too. He may have the same values you do. I'd
put it in terms of that and say, "Listen.
The way I'm being managed, I have family and
integrity as a value and heres what I mean
by that.
This isn't working for me, like on a human,
this isn't working for me. Tell me your values
and I'll respect those. I gotta have that
back." I would say you have a better chance
of actually fixing and helping that person
professionally and personally than if you
just take off. OK? Any other questions? Yeah.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: What are recommendations
that you have for spending time dedicated
to self-awareness?
>>Stan Slap: I personally spend no time dedicated
to self-awareness. I wrote the book. That's
enough. I believe think deep, live shallow.
That's my personal motto for living. I think
self-awareness is a beautiful thing. Like
I said, there's so many influences on you.
Anybody trying to sell you anything stands
to profit from you not having a strong sense
of self. 'Cause again, if you don't know what's
true for you, I've got unusual influence.
So, I would make it a habit to stay self-aware,
just as a corrective measure to all the influences
in the world.
How do you do that? The best way to do it
is to surround yourself with people who know
what you're trying to do and take some value
out of that. That's why in the book, I put--.
It's definitely a process for managers, but
there's also process how to adapt it, how
to take it home, how to do it with your partner,
if you have kids.
How to take this with your kids, your community,
however you do this. So, I think there's tremendous
value in self-awareness. Although, the people
who study it the most avidly are the most
dim, least aware people I've ever met, but
that's just coincidence.
I think if you stay self-aware by surrounding
yourself with people who understand that you're
trying to do that and you're holding yourself
to that standard and they find value out of
that, that's the best way. And I would advise
anybody to pick a couple of methods that work
the best for them and to live a life of intention.
This is no time, in the world, to not live
a life of intention. Yeah. Congratulations,
by the way.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: [audience member
responds off mic]
>>Stan Slap: Oh, yeah. I know.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: So you said there's
some organizations that have gone through
your program here at Google. And you said
they didn't reject it, but they struggled
with it. So I'm curious to know, were they
cultural things or were they things we see
in other organizations--
>>Stan Slap: That's a good question. Why did
they struggle with it? Some of it was cultural
and some of it was having to make the case
that the opposite of emotional is not rational.
The opposite of emotional is detached. So,
don't think about it that--.
Emotion in the human brain is a highly rational
process. It's just capable of producing wonderfully
irrational responses. So, a lot of it was,
what is this? Is this some soft woo-woo stuff?
Which clearly it was not. So, some of it was
just a bias of Google, the renowned bias of
Google, to lean on the intellectual.
And once they understood there was an actual
schematic to this--it's been pretty well documented
and proven--they relaxed. Part of it was just,
what happens to a manager? It's just a weird--.
Are you a manager? OK. Well, hopefully I haven't
talked you out it here.
There's just weird stuff that happens to managers,
even in the best companies. Like the thing
I was telling you about earlier. I tell you
that the most difficult, and this my answer
to your question, the most difficult part
of writing the book was the duality the reader
as a manager.
There's just something that happens to managers.
If this was a room full of managers, I could
take any two of you out and talk to you about
how you wanna live and work and live at work.
And you'd be pretty sane and sensible about
that, as managers are. If I bring you back
and put you in a room full of other managers,
some bizarre herd mentality takes over and
you start legislating against yourself.
Because the conditions that managers deplore
most about managing, there's no evil brain
in a jar behind a curtain. They were created
and mandated and accepted by managers acting
as management, the Honor Guard of the Corporate
Organism. And what managers learn is that
if I set you free to pursue your own values
and your own priorities, maybe you won't prioritize
the company.
I mean, what if you have creativity as a value
and you work for me? And I say, "OK, and this
is what we have to do." And you go, "Yeah,
I love that. It's a values thing. I ain't
doing it. I'm free to make creativity as a
value. I have health as a value. I'm not working
like this.
I have integrity as a value. I'm not representing
this product until it is fully tricked out."
And so, managers learn to just stop this in
themselves and stop it in others. That's management
worldwide. So basically, the answer to your
question, there were some fighting against
the initial bias against something that seemed
soft and stupid.
When they realized it was not soft and stupid,
the next question was, "Gee, can I really
sell this to myself? If I've detached, I did
that because I think it's safe to be detached
from my relationship with the company, with
the people. You're asking me to be unsafe.
I gotta think about that.
Can I sell this to my people? Can I still
be a manager and get done what I have to get
done?" We worked through all that stuff. I
don't think there's any real barrier at Google
that will prevent this at all 'cause they
really bought into it. But there is a barrier
from being a manager that is the same the
world over.
That takes a while. Did I answer your question?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: Yeah. And the
next question would be for those of us who
might not be managers, but worked a lot with
managers across the companies, the selling
the-, the putting yourself in a place that's
potentially unsafe feeling for you being actually
beneficial?
>>Stan Slap: Yes. Yes. No, I mean that's--.
What's that?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: So, I think that
the second part of the question is then once
you've identified that part of the resistance,
is that we're essentially asking people to
put themselves in a place that's potentially
emotionally unsafe? And once they recognize
that, then how do we convince them, or do
we try to convince them that that actually
is beneficial both for them and for the work
that they're trying to get done?
>>Stan Slap: That's a challenge. It's gonna
take both. And that's why the book is written
both for--. Every manager has a manager. I
mean, you know who Mother Teresa's boss was?
Who really her boss,
the person who did her performance appraisals?
It was the Pope. OK? You think you got problems?
Your boss just thinks he's the Pope. Her boss
was really the Pope. And so, she had a manager.
Everybody's got managers. And this is not
gonna work with the manager not being able
to make it a value and a safe proposition
for you, and you not able to help the manager
feel that way, too.
That's what the book is about. It's the right
question. It can be done. We've used it all
over the world. It can be done. Here. It can
be done at Google. OK. Thank you.
[applause]